this is the uh serious cov2 mutation
tracking and genomic data visualization
talk and the speaker is albert chen an
associate computational biologist
in the vector engineering group at the
broad institute of mit and harvard
albert's the project lead on the coven
19
project that he's going to talk about
and contributes to gene therapy efforts
of the vector engineering group he has
primary experience in web development
in the last five years is splitting his
time between
dry lab which is in essence computer
work and wet lab which is actually
um i mean real lab work
so um albert i'm gonna hand off
the um i'm gonna hand out the screen to
you
great thanks mark can everyone see the
presentation okay
awesome um should we wait till the
7 30 or just start just start now
i think you can start now okay great
um yeah so thanks thanks mark for the
introduction
um by the way um i'll be open to
uh questions anytime during the talk you
can just on your
there's like a raise your hand feature i
haven't used it but
we might go over some biology concepts
that might not be familiar to some of
you so
please feel free to ask questions um i
think
we initially i tried to keep the talk at
30 minutes but
i think i'm to go over a bit um that's
going to be okay right mark
okay great so
just as a um just as a disclosure the
this co
our code cg team has a sponsored
research screen with astrazeneca who is
a coed 19 vaccine and therapeutics
developer
and xinghei jhan who is part of the
covent cg team is also a co-founder of
fusion genomics corp which is
does develop some molecular diagnostics
for copper 19 testing
okay so um i'll be splitting today's
talk up into three parts i'll be
actually spending most of my time
talking about sort of uh
cover 19 stars cov2 biology and these
rising variants that you might
have heard about on the news um then
i'll go through an abbreviated
story about how we built code cg so this
is more of like a technical perspective
on things and then i'll end up
i'll end with some perspective on how i
think um
you know the data science community and
this great community can can play a part
in advancing science
biology therapeutics and global health
um
you know play a play a big role in in
the in biology and data moving forward
okay so yeah starting out with some
introduction on cover 19.
um so kovit is is not going away
there's a wide range of predictions last
year but i think it's clear
now that we won't be out of the woods
for a while um even
i i pulled this data from about two
weeks ago so it's a little bit out of
date but
um even even with 70 million
uh americans fully vaccinated in 120
million receiving their first dose we're
still
at a rate of about 50 000 new cases per
day
um and i think you know there's been
some news going around how we might
not reach herd immunity depending on
vaccine hesitancy and other factors
um can't really speak to making any
predictions but i think it's clear that
it's not just going to go away in the
next year so
it's this is going to stay with us
and covet is also not just a problem in
the u.s it's a global problem
viruses don't really care about national
borders because
and while it's coveted is getting better
in the us relative to our big peak in
january it is getting worse around the
world so in particular we have
brazil and india are going through their
worst waves in the pandemic
just like our worst wave was back in
december january february they're going
through their worst waves right now
um but yeah why does why does this
matter why do we care about other
countries we live in the u.s
or most of us uh this is a pi data
boston group it's because
sars kobe 2 this uh this word up here is
this is the name of the virus that
causes carbon 19 so i'll be
saying that term a lot um sorry v2 is
mutating and the more human host it
infects
the more chances it has to mutate
already we have strains imported into
the us which were initially detected
abroad
one of the most prominent ones is this
uk variant
the general scientific consensus is that
this variant is more transmissible
between people and it's also now the
most common source of new infections in
the us and this was originally detected
in the uk
uh we have our and also in addition to
being more transmissible this strain has
also been reported to be
um deadlier than the original sars kobe
2.
we have this brazilian strain so this
strain has become the dominant
brazil's epidemic and in this article
here the authors hypothesized that
this variant could potentially be
reinfecting patients that have
previously contracted stars kobe 2
um it has just has generally higher
higher transmissibility and more
antibody invasion
you also may have seen the south african
variant on the news
and in this current paper the authors
show that the astrazeneca vaccine
which is not approved in the us but is
approved elsewhere actually
just is not very effective at dealing
with uh the south african variant
um and when i made these slides
initially i just had these three samples
but even just within the past two weeks
um
india's recent coven 19 searches brought
to light this new indian variant
which we don't know a whole lot about
but we're definitely keeping our eyes on
so um again these mutants are not these
these variants are not just around the
world they've already made it into the
u.s all
four of the ones that i've shown this
this b.1.1.7 which is also known as this
uk variant
you'll see here in north america is now
the most predominant source of new
infections
um and we have other variants like
brazil variant that are rising i did not
show the south african indian bearing
but they are
they do exist in the us just in very
small numbers
for as of as of right now
um and i don't oh sorry yeah just
highlighting that in north america
uh i don't really want to be like too
like doom and gloom about things about
how the world's ending
um i think one silver lining from this
pandemic is that
the development of these mrna vaccines
the pfizer bio intake vaccine and the
modern vaccine
um i think it's amazing these mrna
vaccines work
really really really well and i
mentioned that the
south african variant renders the
astrazeneca vaccine
which is not an mrna vaccine ineffective
this moderna
moderna did an internal study in the lab
so not on humans which
showed that the neutralizing activity of
their
vaccine went down about six times when
tested against the south african variant
again this is in a lab setting so
not totally translatable to the real
world but i think they found that in
this lab setting even though their
vaccine worth six times less well it was
still within the effective range
which means that um you know
hypothetically that this
affects the modern mrna vaccine would
still provide full protection
to people uh exposed to the south
african bearing which is great
it works so well that it can take a
six-fold hit and still work
uh and we see a similar result with the
fizer bioin-vaccine when tested against
the uk variant as well
and another amazing feature of these
mrna vaccines is that they can be
developed and adapted really quickly
a little known fact is that the the
moderna mrna vaccine was designed in
just two days the rest of the time was
spent in production
and in clinical trials and since
modifying uh these mrna vaccines is just
modifying some of this genetic mrna code
we can adapt these existing vaccines to
fight these new variants so moderna
right now is piloting
uh one version of its vaccine to protect
against the south african very much i
just mentioned before
okay so i guess like the point of me
talking about these vaccines is that uh
the the in these variants is that this
sars kobe 2 the virus that causes cova
19 is evolving which means that
everything we do
to fight coven 19 must also evolve
and our pandemic response is not just
limited to the vaccines i was just
talking about
coven 19 uh coco 19 tests so getting
tests for cobin 19
relies on knowing a certain portion of
the virus genetic code so if this
genetic code mutates in so much to our
diagnostic test
um and while everyone's really focused
on vaccines at the moment i think our
diagnostic tests are
really critical for being able to get
our lives all back to normal again
we're all developing therapeutics which
differ from vaccines in that these
therapeutic treatments are designed to
blunt severe covet 19 symptoms so these
are for people that have already
experiencing severe
copen19 symptoms that have already
gotten it not for preventing in the
first place
i think one really prominent example of
a therapeutic was this regeneron
antibody cocktail that former president
trump
received when he contracted the virus
on also on public policy front so i
think staying on top of the virus can
really help inform public policy
if we're if we're aware of a concerning
variant abroad then we can implement
stricter travel controls
or better quarantine policies to prevent
it spread to the us we
have not been particularly successful so
far but i think this is something that
we could
make an effort to in the future if we
are aware of these variants earlier
okay so yeah before we go on i just want
to just get this definition out of the
way about
what's a mutation what's a variant so
the scars cov2 genome is
30 000 bases long 30 000 characters long
where a character is a t
c or g and it's kind of funny to me
because biologists express
this genetic information in i think
similar terms as
uh to computer scientists explain their
data so at 30 000 bases we usually
shorten this to say it's 30 kb
where kb stands for kilobases almost
like kilobyte
except it's not a byte it's a letter in
this case
um and yeah in terms of evolution
viruses are just like every other living
organism on this planet they mutate and
evolve
and are affected by natural selection um
you know most of these times
so i'm just showing here some mutations
on this genome
most of these times these mutations do
nothing the mutations are never
intentional they're always random but
sometimes they will randomly change the
behavior of the virus and these can be
selected for via natural selection
some and again just like us these
mutations are hereditary and they can
accumulate as the pandemic continues
so a variant or strain as you might hear
called is a set of viruses that are
evolutionarily
evolutionarily related um so viruses
with a common ancestor
so here i'm showing a plot from this
next strain site where we have
sampled a bunch of these different
viruses all
now and you can see that they all share
this common ancestor here in the middle
and they're all branching out
into these diverse groups of variants
and strains
and i also just want to address a common
misconception
about about sequencing versus coping 19
testing so a common misconception is
that when you take a covet test that is
that the spiral genome is actually
sequenced
kova testing is actually much simpler
than genome sequencing as we only rely
on detecting about 100 base pair
segment of the sars cov2 genome this is
about only like 0.3
of the genome and these tests will only
give a binary result it's either
positive or negative
so as a result cova tests are really
cheap to run and they can be massively
scaled up
um our facility at the broad institute
has about like a one day record of 150
000 covered cases
or coveted tests sorry um
and yeah sometimes these positive cova
tests are sent to sequencing centers
these are physically different locations
than these testing centers
and the cost is usually higher the
throughput is usually lower and the
turnaround time is usually longer
so as a result the majority of positive
cobin 19 cases are not sequenced in the
u.s that percentage is about point seven
percent
so we only sequence about seven out of
every thousand
one thousand copic cases
and this sequencing is actually happens
at various different efforts around the
world
so here i'm showing a map where the
darker colors represent more sequencing
done relative to the number of positive
cover 19 cases so
whereas the us sequence is about seven
out of one thousand
positive covert 19 cases the uk sequence
is almost 10 times the amount
um and we have countries that are doing
even more sequencing where australia is
sequencing almost half of their positive
covered cases so
this is really advantageous for them
being able to stay on top of what's
happening
genetically with with covenant 19. and
we also have some countries
like those i highlight in the beginning
brazil and india who are um
sequencing much less relative to the
magnitude of their pandemics and again
this makes it a bit harder to know
what exactly is going on
um yeah and our reporting of this data
has actually attracted some press
attention and
uh if you're interested in learning more
we display this data and
in a lot more detail on the front page
of our covent cg website
okay so um that's the introduction i
think now you all
this talk is about this tool that we
built code cg so what is our what does
our site actually do
uh i'm just showing here a screenshot of
i think one of the most powerful
tools in our site is just a way to it's
just a way to filter data
um oh sorry i think i just noticed that
there is some
questions in the chat um i'll address
those right after these few slides sorry
uh um so yeah i think
uh there's the existing interface for
selecting these genomes is
uh we wanted to we wanted to just
improve on this so we have
uh we hope we have this this more
intuitive interface first
for really drilling down into the data
to get to have really detailed answers
for example if you're a public health
policy professional in massachusetts you
want to know
what kind what variants of covet are
swimming around massachusetts in the
last month and you can answer these
questions
in a really targeted way um so yeah once
the data is selected
we here prevent like present an overview
of these selected genomes
here i'm selecting this b.1.1.7
variant which is the uk variant sorry
let me just replay that video
you can also see that when we have these
we have these data it starts out as
counts and these counts can be sort of
biased depending on how much sequencing
is done in the given day so we have the
option to change these two percentages
um and then once we've also selected
this data we can also compare between
locations so here i've selected a bunch
of various states and just showing that
we have
various levels of this uk variant um in
different states so for example i think
it's the highest in florida and the
lowest in california as of
um about two weeks ago
and i think some of the most you know
powerful features of our covered cg site
is that actually the data downloads not
necessarily visualization parts but
we've
um with this we've we've noticed that
researchers and scientists have
you know been the most excited just
about getting getting their hands on the
data and being able to run their own
plots
make their own plots and run their own
models
okay sorry for skipping these questions
i'll get to them so
ben asked how do they decide which
variants to test the vaccines against
are they
testing everything or just ones with a
certain number of cases
uh that's a good question um i'm not
sure what the selection process
is um
i think whenever one of these i at least
internally in these companies whenever
one of these variants pops up worldwide
they will
um they were they will immediately test
their vaccine against it and their or
their therapeutics against it to make
sure it still works and i think if
if maybe it starts to show signs of not
working just like that during a study
did then they will
maybe target it for what we might in the
future call it a booster shot
um but again i'm i'm not 100 sure
um adam asked why are we not sequencing
more that's a great question
um so going back to
this previous slide you'll see that
there's a really wide range of
sequencing efforts between countries
i think a lot of this is actually um due
to
sort of incentives in science and
government policy so the uk
and i'm not 100 sure about these other
countries but i
i know for the uk that the government
has actually invested a lot
into sequencing um there is actually
this big debate about this uk variant
which i'm talking about um
which uh it was it was initially
detected in the uk because the uk
sequences so much of their virus we
don't actually know if it originated in
the uk it might
it may very well have originated in a
different country jumped to the uk and
the uk caught it because they're
sequencing so much
and this is just one of the benefits of
staying on top of things and sequencing
a lot
so yeah to answer your question i think
a lot of it has to do with um
just incentives i think sequencing's
expensive scientists will not spend
their money and their free time
sequencing
coven 19 and unless they can you know
get something out of it
and this is something we've also seen
with a lot of groups around the world
that will sequence a lot of genomes but
wait a couple months
before they release it because they want
to get a paper out
and yeah i think that the uk has done a
really good job of aligning the
incentives with the public and trying to
get the state out
as quickly as possible so yeah i think
certainly the us can do a lot better in
terms of um
sequencing more
uh yeah so christine asked what's the
purpose of sequencing to learn exactly
which variant it is
yeah that's exactly right um i think
going back to
this slide it's it's just the the virus
is going to change i think
right now the virus is still relatively
similar to
the first version of the virus that came
out of wuhan about a year ago
i think in next year or in two years or
three years of coba 19 is still sticking
around that it will
change dramatically in that all the
things that we rely on to fly cover 19
right now
like our coveted tests that you might
that you might take at local testing
centers or
therapeutics or even our vaccines might
need to be updated so
we just need to stay on top of these
variants and know what they are so that
we can really quickly
respond to these mutations
yeah sorry also feel free to unmute and
ask me questions uh i don't i don't mind
being interrupted at all
so is there is there a plugin where you
can also look for the gene
that the mutation is in s or m or n or e
with gene yeah so all the
all the um let me go back to the to the
site
sorry for that blurry image um yeah all
the um
all the examples i'm showing here are in
the spike gene because that's the most
therapeutically relevant gene
but in our site we allow selecting for
any any of the
genes in the source codeb2 genomes yes
so the es any of the
proteins in the orfs we also have
additional if we go back to
the selector you'll see that we allow
selecting a gene you can select by
protein we allow searching by primers
and probes
um so for people that are developing
diagnostics they can they can make sure
that their diagnostics are still working
within their local area that they're
testing their populations in uh and we
also allow for
matching like custom coordinates or
sequences so we allow selecting any
arbitrary
span of the of the chronovirus genome
yeah right
and can you submit your sequence
like the sub if you have a source code
sequence
can you upload it and compare it with
your data set
so we pull from the gsa database which
is this global database where everyone
submits their sequences so we would only
get your data if you would submit to
this just say database first we also
have a version of the site that pulls
off of genbank which is another
database of um stars kobe 2 sequences
but it's it's a lot smaller
um sorry christine i see your question
i'll get to you in a second um
but yeah i think an important thing to
note is that this covet cg
this covet cg website is also open
source so if you want to
if you want to run this application
locally that you can do this on your
computer and load your own sequences if
you want
um all right christine i saw you had a
question
hi uh i have a follow-up question to the
one that i just
asked yeah sure
so the the reason to do this sorry i'm
not familiar with biology but the reason
to do the sequencing is to know exactly
which variant it is
so i was wondering so earlier you had a
few slides
about every part of the world like uh i
don't know
maybe in the past 12 months
uh for example in the us or in north
america
the percentage of cases that is actually
like b7
the the uk variant yeah
so so basically this slide the data here
i
is it's not like 100 accurate because
you said we are not
really doing the sequencing yeah you're
right the data
the data is biased yeah um so they
should they could be more
yeah i think you're totally right you
know we only sequence we sequence less
than one percent of positive
cases and i think our even our positive
cases i think
we have a lot of people that get code
that don't that don't report that they
have code
they don't get tested um so yeah i think
this is this is just a very imperfect
snapshot
of what's going on and i think we should
sequence more so that we get a better
idea of which
variants are exist where and how
prevalent they are
um yeah that's a great point i think
also in terms of like you'll see that
there's much more wilder swings as we
get closer to today
and these plots and that's just because
these sequences have not been submitted
yet this data
closer to now is a lot more sparse um so
we have to
we do have to when we whenever we
interpret this code sequencing data we
have to understand that it's
um that it's that it is imperfect and
that it is biased i think also
you know who who gets sequence and who
doesn't there's also a bias there could
be bias
in um you know that this is not a
uniform sample of the population
so yeah that's a great point thank you
uh so we have some more questions uh so
from
i'll take uh i'll take like three more
of these and then i'll move on to the
rest and then i'll come back around
at the end of the talk to these that's
okay yeah
um so net how many variants have been
identified are there
areas of the virus structure that mutate
more frequently than others
um yeah that's a great question i'm not
sure the exact number of variants have
been identified i know it's in the
hundreds
i think most variants are um you know if
we go to
skip this next string picture
there there's different ways of defining
a variant i think uh on the next strain
site they actually have a
you know wider definition of variant
where there's only about like 10 or
12 i'm not sure but much less than
the notation i was using you know the
b.1.1.7 is
i guess like a more detailed um way of
grouping these
the grouping is arbitrary it's or not
arbitrary but the grouping is
sort of like human defined it's it's not
like an intrinsic fact
of nature it's it's how we think about
the data it's how we group the data
ourselves
um and are there areas of virus
structure that mutate more frequently
than ours yes definitely
um i think just like any other organism
there's parts of the virus that are
amenable to mutation in parts that are
not
um if you think you know if we think
about humans
uh as a as an analogy it's we have a lot
of genetic variation in height because
whether or not someone's taller or
shorter doesn't really affect
their survival at least in today's
today's society
whereas we also have some areas of our
body which really can't be mutated right
like
we can't make our heart drastically
bigger or smaller because that would
present some really bad
you know medical effects so same thing
with a virus there's some parts of the
virus that are really critical for it to
function that
when it's mutated the entire thing
breaks down and there's some parts of
the virus that are actually advantageous
to mutate especially if it's trying to
escape from vaccines or therapeutics
the spike gene that i was talking about
earlier is you know one of the most
mutated
portions of the carnivorous genome
uh so
yeah feel free to speak up and let me
know if i didn't answer your question
the way you wanted it to i could always
go into more detail
a yang asked i'm curious if there are
certain markers or gene sequences that
suggest vaccine efficacy or inefficacy
if mutated um yeah there's there's
certain portions
of this of this spike gene which people
there's some great work by jesse bloom's
lab
where they actually test a lot of these
sites on the genome
and see if they are um more
i guess not sure how to put this but um
if if they are more uh likely to affect
you know resistance or escape from from
vaccines or therapeutics than other
sites um
so i think they they also have a really
great website about visualizing this um
i kind of regret i don't have a link to
it in this presentation um
but yeah i think a lot of this they
actually generate that data via
tests they they they test this all in
the lab and
we really can't know what i'm testing so
i think with some of this data that
people generated we can make predictions
but
we we would have to test it yeah
physically
okay i'm going to continue but i'll come
back around to some of these other
questions
just in the interest of keeping the face
going but thank these are all great
questions thank you
um okay so
yeah for the next part of the talk i'll
just go into how we develop the sites
and challenges we encountered along the
way
i just want to preface this by saying
the site is very much still in
development i don't want to present
our site a success story i think we have
much to add and much to improve i just
hope to tell
a story that i hope you'll find some
parts of it interesting
um or maybe relatable so
uh this project started with a couple of
scientists in our lab
we started this project because
analyzing these stars kobe 2 genomes
just takes way too long
it's just too hard or not too hard but
very time consuming
so first these genomes and metadata have
to be downloaded separately as separate
files from the from this just a database
which i mentioned earlier
then we have to run this quality control
we have to filter out
low quality genomes then we have to dig
through these genomes and extract
mutations and this is actually a really
computationally intensive process
after all of that they could finally run
the analyses that they wanted to run in
the first place
and on top of this the data is changing
every day these new sequences are being
added every day
so whenever they wanted to update to the
newest data they had to repeat this
entire process
so our goal after experiencing this
firsthand was not just to streamline
this process but
to and not just to do it for ourselves
but to make this process data available
to other researchers and other
scientists so they wouldn't have to go
through the same struggles that we did
i had to make some key decisions as i
started to build the site so
first i decided to not use any of these
i guess when i'm turning like unified
solutions like our shiny or plotly dash
or a bookie server
i've used some of these in the past i
think while they're really really great
really
quick to put together um i found it
i had to hack my way around problems i
found that they didn't deal with like
really large amounts of data very well
which is
sort of the data that we have so instead
i started with this
boilerplate kit called react slingshot
which sort of made all these
architecture decisions for me
i just really went for react because
i've used it extensively on some prior
projects and i've also worked with some
of the other tools listed here these
might be familiar to some of you
so for plotting we had like a ton of
options to choose from there's many many
many javascript plotting libraries
i had vega on my radar for a while and i
decided to use it because
i think it's you know more expressive
than some of these
higher level libraries like plotly and i
think not as hard to learn as
these lower level libraries like d3
and another thing i loved was that vega
we wanted the site to be interactive we
thought that vega was
really built from the ground up to be
interactive just like uh d3 is as well
uh one of the example plots from vega
that caught my attention was that
someone actually wrote pac-man and the
way that um
vega is designed it's it's you define a
plot with a json file so someone wrote
pacman json which i thought was really
it was just really neat and sort of um
kind of proved to me the expressive
an interactive power of vega
um and so next uh just talking about
some of the data processing
um when we so this is the
this is the just say database just a
preview of the site
uh when we first started i would have to
actually process all this data manually
i know that i mentioned our goal is to
streamline the process but we
figured that first just putting in the
manual leg work would allow other
research groups
to say to save time from doing the same
thing so well i would download these uh
i would download these sequences and
metadata files store them locally in my
computer
there's no public api for this site so
you just have to do this manually
then we would manually run extraction
scripts from these genomes
and aggregate them all into one file and
extracting mutations
from genomes is actually very very you
know computationally intensive at least
the way
we were doing it so a long story short
requires like mountains and mountains of
ram and to do this we actually had to
use these high memory
vms from google cloud that had like 600
gigs of ram available
um and even then some of the data
processing would take hours
and then we kind of ran into the problem
of like we have these 50 000 genomes
it's a lot of data how do we actually
serve the clients genomic data is quite
large so we can't just rely on some like
classic
classic solutions meant for smaller
amounts of data so we first considered
this conventional database server client
model
uh we decided it was pretty hard it
would require a lot of work
um the second solution that we
considered was what if we could just
stuff all of our data into a json file
and then just gzip it
um just compress it and then host it on
like a static file hosting solution like
google cloud storage
which is the equivalent of amazon s3 um
this is really simple but we also have
to engineer some asynchronous requests
into our javascript application i know
it's not that much work but
um i guess like our third solution was
just to do this manually it was just to
take our data and just directly inline
it into our javascript bundle so package
everything together into one request
and we ended up going with the last
solution because here we were
our mindset at least when we were
developing this project was that this
was in may of 2020 that
you know covid was still really serious
that we wanted to develop this as an
emergency response like we want to get
the site out there as quick as possible
so that it can be used
by scientists as quick as possible so
yeah some of these solutions were a bit
dirty and hacky at first um so yeah this
we just we did this all manually
manually downloaded data manually
processed it manually inlined it into
javascript bundles and manually uploaded
each new build every day
to uh vm on google cloud
um i just want to quickly go over that
like i'm not a developer by training i
don't really know the latest trends in
web technology i don't know
best practices that are employed by the
big development companies so i enlisted
the help of
my friend kevin who's a senior web
developer at a big tech company
he just suggested that we replace some
components in our initial boilerplate
app and really put in a lot of work to
glue everything together so
just want to do this as a shout out that
his changes are really essential to the
app's development and i'm not really
sure it would have worked out then
um so yeah after all this we finally
ended up our first functional build of
code cg this is
much simpler than the version of the
site that's up now it's just one plot
and one table
but i think some scientists in in our
group found it immediately
useful for their research
um yeah so next i just want to quickly
go over some additional automation that
we did so
there's this really great data workflow
tool called snake make which is just
like a make file just like people use
for c and c plus plus but for python
um it builds this really cool like
dependency graph for our data which
means that if we add like a new file
it'll only run
jobs for the for the file that change
it'll only update the necessary nodes
so this allowed us to sort of automate
what used to be
like manual script running um and this
drastically cut down the amount of
manual work we had to do each day
although we still had to
manually download data from the gs8
website
and yeah after some additional
automation we were eventually able to
make this 100 hands off so first of all
we were able to get access to an api
from just said
that we no longer had to download
manually download data every day
and we expanded our pipeline to make
calls to the api and also
automatically upload data to google
cloud storage and we did this all
once per day via cronjob and we also
moved our server from
our manually managed vms to google cloud
run which runs off of docker container
so this is like an auto scaling thing
that can adapt
or scale to a large amount of requests
say that
if our site gets published in cnn which
it did and we got a ton of traffic and
this all just handled that fine whereas
i think the vmware just would have just
crashed
um and so yeah now i think we have this
process
mostly automated which is great
um another really quick thing i want to
go over is that we
solicited some early feedback from a lot
of different scientists both from abroad
and from
from from around the world actually um
uh so yeah we had many users who are
currently performing covered research
back in 2020
um we had them use our tool and give us
feedback and a lot of this feedback was
really crucial for
for the vision of our site moving
forwards
um so yeah after months of work we
finally launched our site to the public
we published a paper
um we got some press attention and over
the last few months we've just been
gradually fixing bugs improving
performance and
have some plans to add some new features
to the site
um i just want to quickly talk about
this the state of disaster
so about a month and a half ago i was i
was notified that
that our app had stopped loading which
was like a big nightmare um
so i sort of jumped on and tried to see
what was happening
uh so just for context when we started
the app we only had there was only 50
000 chronovirus genomes publicly
released this is about 30 megabytes the
way we package the data
if we compress it goes down to like two
megabytes which is like you know
five or ten seconds of the youtube video
so it's a relatively small file size
and this is a big reason for why we
decided to go with this like inline data
solution earlier is because
we really didn't have that much data and
in may or june of last year we figured
at the current rate of submission that
in about a year we'll have maybe like
200 000 sequences you know it's still
it's a lot of data but it's still again
it's not it's not too much
um at the end you can see here that in
real life the actual rate of sequencing
has
really skyrocketed um at the time of the
crash our
site was handling data from over or the
site was sending over 700 000 genomes to
our clients
so compress this was about like 30
megabytes this is actually like a really
big download but
for a fast internet connection didn't
take more than a minute
um uncompressed this data exploded to
about 500 megabytes and
just as a surprising little like tidbit
that i found when you open chrome task
manager i found that
even after you know loading 700 000
genomes
into the browser our app was still
taking less ram than gmail was which is
kind of weird
i don't know whether it says more about
gmail or us um
but yeah anyway after after looking up
our you know our errors i found that
google chrome
refuses to parse any json that's larger
than 512 megabytes
and at first i was actually like super
annoyed so i was like this is such a
stupid
arbitrary rule of google chrome and then
i was thinking about it more as like
actually you know it's this is pretty
reasonable
to not parse json over 512 megabytes
this is actually an okay limit um
so yeah now now that we have like a
million genomes how do we serve a
million genomes now that we can't just
inline it all into into a javascript
bundle or serving
just one big json file um it's funny
because we started that sort of the
laziest solution and slowly moved back
to sort of the more principled solution
of having a database and a server and a
client
which can you know serve only small
chunks of the data that that the user
requests and this is what is live now
um so this is like sort of the version
two of code cg
i was actually working on this a while i
i anticipated that this would happen one
day just wasn't anticipating what
happened so soon
um so now we have data being loaded into
postgres that's communicating with the
flask server and that class
server is is communicating with the
front-end app right now
um yeah so just lessons learned i think
um
i don't know i always think about that
programmer meme where it's like i can
spend five minutes doing it manually or
i could spend like four hours automating
it
and i think you know the answer from
that meme is that like yeah just do it
manually like how
all programmers do is like what they
want to automate stuff um
i think that if i sat down and sort of
wrote out how much time i would be
spending each day doing manual work that
i would you know come to the conclusion
that i should actually automate
much much earlier so i think sort of
thinking about the future and
thinking about what automation can do
can do for us
would have helped me a lot back then um
so i think also asking for help was
really was
was really helpful for me um i think i
realized that i'm not
really i'm an amateur programmer i
didn't really learn this in school um it
was really
i think a lot of the technical direction
of the site was driven by
my uh kevin the senior web developer and
a lot of
the also a lot of like the scientific
direction and the design direction was
driven from these scientists that we
interviewed early on in the process
um and then lastly just about
scalability but we have wasted
you know a lot of time just putting out
fires and
having to deal with these large bumps
and traffic and just having a scalable
solution from from day one would have
saved us a lot of time as well so
um i see we have questions i'm almost
done with the talk so i'll get to them
i'll get to them soon
i know i'm running very much over time
so
um but i'm almost done
uh yeah for the last part of the talk i
just want to discuss um
the future of not just data science in
the covid field but also across biology
and how
skilled data scientists that don't
necessarily have biology expertise
can help advance science and global
health
so i think biology and data are growing
ever and ever and ever closer here i'm
showing the cost of dna sequencing
and blue from just the year 2000s now
and
it's it's outpacing by a massive pace
moore's law for semiconductors um
so and this is just an example of
genomic sequencing i think in every
field of biology that we just have
massive reams and reads of data being
generated now
and it's not just like the 1 million
stars cov2 genomes it's also
initiatives like the uk biobank which is
sequenced over 100 000 human genomes
it's like
these protein sequence databases which
are behind google deepmind's alpha fold
project which some of you may have heard
of
and i think that this you know this
massive amount of data allows
people working in data science and
biology to solve really interesting data
problems
not just solving cool biology problems
because i always kind of found it ironic
that um
at least a lot of my friends are
computer scientists and they spend all
their time in school learning about data
structures and algorithms
you know algorithm algorithmic
complexity
all this fundamental computer science
stuff but you know in their actual jobs
they never get to use this knowledge and
in biology all these scientists where
amateur programmers
um actually have to put these concepts
into practice because they have so much
data and because they need to be
efficient
and this is just like my anecdotal
experience i know i might be biased here
but um
you know i think that there's tons of
really interesting data science computer
science
algorithms um you know problems like
optimizing algorithms
improving data storage improving query
performance
and even more that are not really
tackled in a lot of conventional
data science industry jobs again i don't
have that much personal experience so i
might be biased but
this is just my opinion um
and i think it's not just like really
technical data visualization problems
it's
um sorry data processing problems
there's also really some interesting
visualization problems i think
biologists aren't just you know amateur
programmers they're also really amateur
visual visualizationists as well
this is an example of the really widely
used ucsc genome browser which is like
an amazing tool
but it has like decidedly old school
look and it's not super intuitive to use
and here's an example of nomad tool that
sort of it's it it doesn't have the same
exact goals
as the genome browser it serves a little
bit of a different purpose but i think
you know nomad is one of the new tools
and you know this new age of sort of
leading
leading the field and finding really
great ways to explore
complicated data like human genomic data
um
so my point here is that like
contributing to this new age of biology
and data science isn't just a purely
technical thing but a lot of these
problems are actually visual
in my opinion it requires the talents of
a lot of creatives like graphic
designers and
visualization specialists to actually
get through these piles of piles and
data
i'm just you know listing a bunch of you
know if you have
specialties in any of these fields i
think that there's a
really large need for for this expertise
in biology
sorry my lights just shut off um
okay just want to thank everyone um
we've had help from a lot of people
and i will take some questions now
okay
so from adam um what types of issues
would be good
for others to help with so yeah like i
mentioned this covetcg project is open
source on github
um which are ilc is it just to track you
know issues and what's going on with the
app
um yeah i'm not sure that that's
something on me i think i have to
i think i should sort start marking
issues as
good for good for first-time
contributors um
but yeah i think i i hope that i've made
the development the
code cg is based on it's based on a
bunch of docker containers
and it's pre-loaded with some example
data so hopefully
if you want to get it up and running
hopefully that process is easy that's
something that i've tried to make using
do we have location data of who is
getting sequenced sometimes
um so
i think depending on which country and
location
we have sequencing data for it the level
of detail as it pertains to location and
patients
really varies just because of patient
privacy laws that vary between different
places
so i think really notably in the uk
they're extremely vague about their
patients whereas sometimes in the us
they can be a bit more detailed but
a lot of this metadata is is sometimes
pretty big
i think in the uk you won't even um
they'll just say it's from england or
wales or scotland they won't go any more
detail than that or sometimes they will
but mostly they don't
one of the to to tack onto that question
one of the things i was curious about is
um
their urban and rural outbreaks are are
often
different in many ways especially in the
response and i wasn't sure if it was
like
i don't actually know when you when
sequencing how far samples will travel
before they get sequenced i wasn't sure
if it was like things that were near
road institute happen to get sequence
more than things that are not near a
road institute or something like that
um i'm not sure the answer i'm not sure
i know the answer to that question
i'm not really familiar with the
logistics of of um
of how samples are come go from testing
centers to sequencing centers
yeah i'm not familiar with that sorry
you said there's some data available is
it
data of where the the it was sequenced
or did it where the
patient was yeah it's data from
uh i guess where the patient is i guess
that's a complicated question because
they could be somewhere and traveling
somewhere else yeah so
actually it was really interesting
because early some of these sequences do
have travel data associated with them so
they'll say that this patient traveled
recently from this place and that's how
they actually can do a lot of this
um a lot of evolutionary tracing
but not with every sequence um so yeah
it's usually about where the patient
lives and sometimes it's
at the town level sometimes it's at the
county level sometimes
state level sometimes it's only at the
country level um it really varies
it's not consistent very cool and
that data is not currently
visible in your tool but it is in gis
or is it and i'm not sure where to click
oh yeah sorry um so just say it is the
database which hosts individual
sequences
our site is serving aggregate data so
we will not display the metadata for any
individual sequence
just based on our terms of service um
right but yeah if you go on the just
aids site and register you can look
at individual sequences and see you know
any metadata
patient if there is any and where
exactly it came from but on our site
we just sort of allow people to select
broad locations and then we collect all
the sequences that are associated to
that location
does that make sense yep uh the
when you select a location it's the
location of the sample not where it came
from though because that's not
or obfuscated by the abstraction
um sorry stop answering my questions go
to somebody else's question
oh no no no worries yeah we don't um we
don't always have travel data so
we haven't really prioritized processing
it but we could in the future
so thank you for the talk it's really
nice a really nice piece of work and
hats off
to kevin as well i wanted to ask you to
go back to one
one slide which was um the first
instance of the ui it had a big screen
stream graph on it
and you're talking about how your users
were really finding that valuable this
one yeah
did you just talk about what your users
were looking for and what
what what what helped them in this view
yeah so this was about i think when we
were interviewing people about
july or august of 2020 um
i'd say that we didn't really have a lot
of these
um scary variants popping up it was just
a few mutations here and there and we
weren't actually looking
we were sometimes looking at variants
but we were actually looking at
individual mutations which our site also
allows you to do is to not look at
these evolutionary related groups of
sequences but actually drill down into
the effects of
you know what is the effect if if this
position the specific position is
mutated
um is that increasing or decreasing in
frequency in these locations
um so i think that's like one big part
they found useful and i think also
what they found broadly useful is just
the ability to sort of use our interface
to filter the data that they want to
look at
and then to download it for their own
purposes because i think
um our site's not always going to
provide the exact visualization they
want i think it's a really quick way to
understand what's happening and then dig
deeper
from there so in a nutshell to start to
be so naive
is they were using us to isolate what
portions of the virus
in the set that they had appeared to
have mutated
um i guess you could you could approach
sort of exploring this fire state from
two angles you either have
a mutation in your head that you want to
explore like you have
this you might hear that like this e484k
mutation in the south african variant
and
the brazil bearing that you that you
open the site and you want to see like
is this in massachusetts is this growing
in massachusetts that's sort of like
mutation-centric approach
and then you might also have this global
surveillance-based approach which is
just like
what's circulating in texas like you
might just want to ask that question so
i guess it depends on
on on what your goal is does that answer
your question
sure sure and and so what what's at
stake for them is
is the design of some sort of uh
not not an intervention but just they're
they're looking at this to figure out
what their policy response should be
yeah and i just yeah are you starting to
grow up to go on
i mean what do they do once they've
identified that yeah this particular
variant
is seems to be pretty active in texas
where do they where do they where do
they
what do they do with that so yeah i
think we would caution against anyone
sort of looking at the plots in their
site and
and making a surefire conclusion about
the the ground truth of things like
like uh sorry i forget the name like one
of um our participants mentioned earlier
that the state is really biased um
it's not you know it might not it may
not be uniformly sampled it's sparse
um it does not necessarily represent the
ground truth so we we see this tool as
sort of
um really rapid hypothesis checking
and motivating people to dig deeper into
the individual sequences
so again like we provide accurate data
we we provide these plots that make it
really
we hope easy to sort of zip around the
data and
ask questions quickly but i think for a
principled
analysis that you have to dig deeper
this is about being able to focus
attention efficiently
yeah exactly okay good thank you thank
you great talk thank you
um sorry just going through more of
these questions so a yang says did you
consider any
parallel pandas libraries like desk mode
in cdf and spark
um yeah actually i again like i'm kind
of a noob at this stuff like i
um you know i read some i read some
forums about some of the new stuff
coming out but i don't necessarily have
the time to try all of them um
yeah definitely i think that the snake
make program i mentioned earlier
um
let's see if i can find it
uh sorry
i thought i had it somewhere here
ah here it is yeah so i mean this this i
think snake make is also
um i guess it's also like a parallel
it has parallel processing features we
usually run it um
in a parallel mode to process all of our
data it's compatible with
different computing clusters like like
slurm or singularity it's compatible
with uh
um not sh yeah those are those are all i
know of but yeah there is some parallel
computing power built into that so um
yeah we i definitely don't run any of
this on like a single thread that would
take forever
um okay yeah last question
from uh kirsten kirsten sorry for
pronouncing that wrong um any advice for
someone with a biomedical background
research in clinical who's new to the
data science field
um yeah i'm
i'm not sure if i'm the best person to
answer this uh
like i i've been i've been sort of
programming as a hobby from
from high school but i think that um
yeah i guess i'm i'm not i i think i
think there's i think there's tons of
opportunity i think like
as with the sort of the best ways to get
started programming to get started in
the project
i think that if you already have your
foot in the door and the company that
you have access to data that um
but yeah i think that these these groups
like this pi data group
any any i don't know if there's any
rivalries between the r groups but i
think you know a lot of the r user
groups are really
really great um uh
i there's a few resources off the top my
head which are great introductions to
sort of analyzing data not necessarily
approaching computer science from the
computer science mindset but approaching
computer science
and data data science from sort of the
scientist perspective like the first
thing you want to do is really plot data
and not learn about
linked lists or something
so yeah i think um
there's if you try to look up there's a
couple of these o'reilly books
um like python for data science
i think is a is a really good one where
they sort of just start you out about
plotting data sort of start out
doing interesting stuff that isn't super
dry i think that's a good way to start
but
that's just my opinion
um okay i'm curious if this tool can be
used to figure out
oh sorry morality asked i'm curious if
this tool can be used to figure out what
exactly is driving increased cases in a
particular location
yeah that's a great question um i'd say
no
this tool cannot be used for that uh
so again like um what i was saying
earlier is that this tool is for really
like rapid hypothesis generation maybe
just like really quickly getting a lay
of the land of
of um how things look like even
even with locations like brazil where
they have this p.1 variant coming out
and they also have this really dramatic
rising cases
um these this research coming out of
brazil
isn't necessarily like at least these
two things are correlated so therefore
they must be causal as well
i think everyone's really careful about
that there could be many many many
factors that drive
increase in the pandemic in a given
location it could be
social behavior it could be genetic
right it could be these variants
it could be government policy uh you
know it could be a wide variety of
things so
we can't really make these conclusions
from from the data on our site at least
yeah adam
i was like why are you talking to me too
much so much um i was i have like two
super technical questions i don't know
if this is
a question maybe for for kevin
potentially too but
um as i was hunting through i am trying
to look at all the example analysis
and one of them one of them loads a
blank page lineage is niceland um
and i noticed that because this is react
not data but when i go through different
places there's no history
um it's all dynamically generated so i
can't hit back
from wherever i am do you know um what
part of the design like we need to
change in order to be able to hit back
and go to the pagerank before
yeah that's a good question um yeah we
should implement like better routing
i think like a lot of this first site
was really just sort of hacked together
because we needed to get it out but yeah
there's definitely many
points for improvement i welcome anyone
using a site that finds any
place where they get stuck or any
problem just open an issue and we'll
the problem there um sorry albert the
problem there is that we're using like
mob x
um and we're using a mobx router uh
which
is a not very well supported like router
and so in order to do this it's gonna
just take a little bit more leg work
than
if you were just to do it like the
standard react router i believe
yeah i don't know anything about react
routers um
[Music]
uh i just know i've seen react apps with
like history and i think i can go google
it and try to figure out a little bit
more information i'm probably not gonna
be able to
actually submit a pr but if you uh mark
one of your issues as good first issue
i'll
uh 100 yeah we'll definitely have to
go through some of our issues and do
that
one one more question about genome
sequencing not not something i'm
familiar with
and uh like you know just the expression
the base pairs looks pretty pretty
unintelligible but that's a lot of
memory to be using to be
sequencing and i'm curious about what
what what makes that so so memory
intensive and
can you can you point me to one thing
that might be good to read about to sort
of understand
what the computation of genome
sequencing is about
yeah i had one slide here that i cut i'm
trying to find it
uh
yeah i was gonna sort of explain a
little bit about sort of the memory
requirements of this um
uh so uh before i go into that there
there is there is a more efficient way
of doing so
than than we are doing it's called it's
called next clade it's
also from this next strain project team
um
and you know they wrote some bespoke
code in cnc plus plus to align these
viral genomes
sort of like i said it's like there's a
lot of inefficiencies in the way
biologists write code that i think can
be improved by
serious programmers and data scientists
so yeah i think i think the question is
is is we have these genomes that are 30
000 characters about 30 000 characters
long the individual characters can
change
they can also be deleted or they can
also have stuff inserted this has
happened in the chronovirus genome so
just as an example here i have sort of
a reference sequence like let's say that
this is this is not the exact sequence
but let's say this is like
um the reference virus from wuhan from
last year and then we have all these
different lineages where you know some
of the
letters change there can be some
deletions there can be
some sorry these are would be
technically insertions
um and i think the big problem here is
that
we have these strings that are 30 000
characters long and we have to find an
optimal global alignment
so that like we have to you know imagine
we first like have this big sliding
window or we slide like 30
000 times except then we also have this
problem of insertion so we can have
certain portions you know skipping
others um
this is what sort of causes this to be
so memory intensive because we have to
solve this entire problem at once
i think the actual algorithms sort of do
a divide and conquer strategy
the reason this next strain or next
clade sorry
um product is so much faster and less
memory intensive that it can even run on
the browser is that you know they've
made some assumptions about this viral
genome that you know made some
optimizations i'm not
exactly sure how it works i won't
comment on that but you know
um they've improved on a more general
tool so yeah
that's that's sort of why this this
process is so connotation-intensive
got it thank you
all right we've any other questions
check the chat sorry
yeah the gcp memory is usually cheaper
than engineering time
that's funny because um yeah that's what
we thought at first
is that you know we could just use these
really beefy vms in the cloud and just
sort of brute force our way through the
data
these vms are actually quite expensive
we could spend like
i don't know maybe like 50 bucks a night
processing some data which doesn't sound
like too much but it really adds up so
we actually used this problem to
motivate buying just like a really big
workstation computer
in our office that um you know
also has some graphics cards for machine
learning stuff but um
you know this having a physical computer
instead of relying on cloud computing
actually
paid for itself within like a month or a
month and a half
um so like the cloud is convenient
i think more than it is cheap yeah
i i hope i know um google and
gcp and abs have been uh throwing out
credits to a lot of groups like
coronaway and other things so
uh broad gets a pretty hefty discount on
gcp as my guess but um
i hope that it doesn't that money is not
preventing
like certain things because i feel like
gcp will give that to somebody if you
ask the right way
yeah we haven't asked i'm not sure if we
get discounts
um i know that we don't pay overhead for
cloud computing that's it
uh
so yeah i think i think that's it albert
thanks for a great talk and uh
thanks for answering the questions you
know um
i it's it's just nice to be able to
learn
exactly how all this is done so thanks
again and a big round of applause i'm
sure from everybody